Want to bring in Misty Marris.
She was a trial attorney.
And Areva Martin, an attorney
and legal affairs commentator. Areva.
This was really a preview
of what we should expect to be presented
during this trial.
What was your biggest takeaway?
Yeah, my biggest takeaway
is that this defense attorney is good
and he came out of the gate
and he challenged
the jury
to basically disregard
everything they had heard
from the prosecutor.
He said, look, these are not facts.
These are theories.
And then he did something
that I thought was really good.
He had Mr.
Murdaugh stand up and he personalized it.
He said, look at this guy.
This is not the guy that would butcher
and brutalize
his son,
that he was just riding around
in a car bonding.
He wouldn't, you know,
shoot his son in the head.
So his brains literally
would explode out of his head.
And he talked about the amount of blood
that would be on anyone that,
you know, someone in that fashion.
Then he talked about the timeline,
that the timeline doesn't work,
that there wasn't enough time
for someone to commit
these brutal murders,
go back to their home,
clean up their body,
change their clothes,
and then get in the car
and exit that property.
So he gave the jurors
lots of things
that they could use to create doubt.
And he basically said,
look here right now, he is innocent.
He did not do this.
And so I think that was
a very powerful statement
by the defense jury.
Yeah.
I mean, he did everything
he could in those opening arguments
to try to humanize his client. Right.
Having them stand up, talking about what
a loving and doting father he was
and that there was a Snapchat video
not long before with his son
where they were laughing.
And then you had the prosecutor
come out of the gate
and talk about this video
that he said was taken
just before the murders at that kennel.
And he says,
you can hear Alex's voice in that video,
which undercuts
what he told police,
that he was in the home
napping after dinner and wasn't there.
How dare mean is that
for the defendant, Misty
So right now, what
we expect to see
a trial is a lot of inconsistencies,
according to the prosecutor,
with respect to those videos.
The body cam footage
that shows what Alec Paul said
as opposed to what the timeline
the prosecution is going to put together,
all seemingly from cell phone data.
This video
that puts him in a place
he said he was not at the time.
So that's certainly going to be
something that will play out.
But we saw the defense get ahead of this.
And to read this, to
sort of flip
the script and say,
well, the prosecution's own experts
are going to put together a timeline
that simply isn't feasible.
Another bombshell
coming out of the defense
opening statement,
this foreshadowing
of an alternate theory of the case.
It seems like
this could have been only done
by two people.
That's something
I think we're going to see more of
as this case goes on.
Alternate theories
proposed by the defense.
All right.
I want to bring in Diane Gallagher
She is there right
outside the courthouse.
She's been following this, Diane.
It's that, as we were just talking about,
the cell phone data
and the defense attorney
was trying to cast
doubt about the data,
saying that there were inconsistencies.
And he had said
Maggie's
phone was used up until 8:54 p.m..
We heard the state prosecutor, I know
did say that her phone stopped
and locked, I believe, at 8:49 p.m.
the same time, around the same time
as Paul.
So already
you see the defense attorney
there trying to raise doubts, poke holes
in the state prosecution's argument
Precisely, Pamela.
And look, you also noticed
that the defense attorney,
Dick Harpootlian,
said that they that he asked who
who unlocked that phone
for law enforcement,
saying that it was Alex Murdaugh
who unlocked Maggie Murdaugh's phone
for them to go through.
Now, look,
the state went through a bit
at the beginning
explaining what the words
circumstantial evidence means and telling
people what reasonable doubt
means, trying to go over the definitions
of those specifically.
That has been something
that the defense has said all along.
But specifically this week
when going over those pretrial motions
about the evidence
and the experts
that the prosecution
wants to introduce into this trial,
talking about the fact
that much of this is circumstantial
there's no smoking gun per se.
They don't have the weapon.
They acknowledge
they do not have the weapon,
although the judge did tell them
they could use a ballistics expert.
This was a pretrial motion
who says that
the casings
that were found in those
around the crime scene
and on the hunting property
in a firing range area
do match that missing weapon
that is sort of
at the center of all of this.
Now, again,
there is some discrepancy
between what the defense claims
and what they claim as well.
Something we're going to see continue
on, of course, in the coming days
is could go up to three weeks,
we're told.
Yeah.
And it's interesting
how both sides try to spin
whatever the evidence is in their favor.
Right. That 911 call.
Prosecutors say, listen to this.
You know, really listen closely.
The defense attorney
said, I want you to listen to that.
Also emphasizing,
you know, the role that he played
in opening the phone for police
and that he called
he called Maggie's phone several times.
After she was killed.
And you know that
the prosecutor is saying
he was trying to create an alibi.
The defense saying, look,
that shows you right there
he didn't know what was going on.
He wasn't involved in this so,
so many different threads
and pieces of evidence to follow in this.
This is just the beginning.
Diane Gallagher, Misty Marris, Areva
Martin, thank you all.